sounds of Freedom yes okay Simple Story
told the story 100 million dollars
crowdfunded Christian movie sound of
Freedom hits 100 million dollars Taps
Mission Impossible Wednesday star called
Trump
amen
[Applause]
I'm assuming you guys saw it I know you
did can you tell us what you're I mean
Matt you and I watch it together in
Bahamas Ricky have you seen it already
or not yes Matt your biggest takeaway
yeah I watch a movie we came back from
Bahamas and then uh on Tuesday in
Oakbrook we had a uh super BLM and then
the next morning on Wednesday morning 11
30 on first show before I left on my
flight Oprah money smart Moon showed up
to the theater we packed it
um I can't
imagine being that father in that movie
who felt so Dagon helpless
knowing that he didn't know who to call
who to talk to
and and he couldn't he can't track his
kids he's poor for example resources
his babies just got taken he's a single
father I was resonating with that
because I was a single father raising my
kids
and I'm asking myself this question too
as well you know we all laugh about that
movie Taken I mean that's people think
it's an action movie what said movie
really it's a human trafficking movie
yeah but we missed it because we had
distracted with an action movie
and and what is Leah Nielsen say in that
movie I have a set of special skills I'm
gonna find you right so I'll ask myself
this question because you always you
know you've always uh coached this
Peabody to always prepare for no matter
what's you know if a distraction is
coming away do you have a action plan
for that so I'm asking myself this
question
who do I call
if my kids are Amber alerted and
kidnapped
that has a special set of freaking
skills to go after somebody like this
and um
and we found them
and we had them on our you know we have
a podcast and we interviewed him
Wednesday and let's talk about a case
study that we're going right now in
Dallas right down the street from Frisco
is Louisville the 17 year old so it's a
working case they're working on right
now it's a 17 year old she's currently
being trafficked since she was 13.
she can't get out the life because of
Pam said you don't want to do this you
don't want to do this they take a selfie
in front of their mom's house
we know your mom lives and if you if you
don't do this we're always going to take
your 10 year old sister we're gonna
bring it to life we're gonna flip her
so she does the job she said I can't do
this more I can't do this fine if you
want to do this morning you need to
recruit your replacement so in the movie
sound of Freedom the recruiters weren't
the guys it wasn't some weird dude in a
mask glasses and a white van it was a
woman
it was an unthreatening person
so this 17 year old girl recruits his 10
year old
and was horrified what happened
so she promises this girl candy and ice
cream
but what she finds is a bunch of guys
that kidnapped her
shattered full of Fentanyl and she had
to hear this 10 year old girl for the
next two hours gang raped
to continue the process of desensitizing
her for the rest of her life is going to
look like so
Christian Muslim Mormon no matter what
left right can we all agree that we
never everyone have that happen to our
kids that's our enemy
that's our enemy we're all distracted
all this [__] but the enemy is what
the drug trade is not even sex more to
the gangbangers
I gotta go all the way and get my
cocaine across the board gotta find a
meal but that
right now is not
the opportunity if you're a gangster
because it's expensive to get a drug
game what do you buy a key for 30k and
you flip it for 60. right or wrong
or how do you know these numbers man I'm
Chicago I've watched Ricky validate
those jokes
you got to get a key so you can you can
be your you know Corner boy you can drug
you in your city
but it's also expensive so for example
if you have crime and you're doing
drive-bys people know what they see a
car and you have a description they're
gonna find you you have drugs people are
in drugs obviously you know by the way
how many guys were raised around people
that you saw in the neighborhood people
on drugs right high it's crazy right how
they look so you can tell there's drugs
in the neighborhood the thing with human
trafficking you can't tell yeah
it's a hidden crime and if you had
caught with drugs you got caught doing
drive-bys you're going to get arrested
you're gonna be prosecuted you're gonna
spend some time in jail the problem with
human trafficking is even if the person
gets caught with the person that they're
pimping out
because they have them in such a lock
they're going to deny that that's their
pimp because if they if they follow
through with it they know where mom
lives they know where the family is so
say I'm that this is my friend and what
happens is there's not enough laws
there's not the whole defund the police
movement guess what they've defunded
human trafficking they didn't learn so
we've had these non-profit organizations
to be the ones there are that are taken
guys Navy Seals and if you're a Navy
SEAL a former law enforcement special
apps there's organizations that are
trying to recruit you right now to be
that Liam Neeson character to go out and
defend us because that is going to be
our next wave like we like low Jack when
kids we are our cars are getting ripped
off right now imagine having to get a
LoJack for your kids
so that's the era that we're facing
right now and anybody that's against
this that's minimizing this that's
coming against this thank you for
exposing yourself we now know where our
enemy is too
so by the way number one that's a man
right there that's a father right there
shout out to Matthew
so seriously Pat recommended we watch
the movie right and I think you watch it
in the Bahamas I was on vacation I don't
know where I was and then I get home and
I see you do a video with like 20 like
an army behind you and you're
encouraging everybody yo go watch this
movie I go watch the movie
and the day before on the podcast we
were discussing it and there was
headlines Rolling Stone certain
magazines articles like disparaging the
movie and basically marginalizing the
whole concept of the movie for sure so I
go into the movie unbelievable already
knowing all right they called it a q
Anon conspiracy theory so I'm thinking
all right let's look for these Clues so
I sit through the two and a half hour
movie and I'm thinking all right like
when's the Q Anon thing coming
when's the right-wing conspiracy thing
coming and it was just generally a movie
about freaking child sex trafficking
period end of story and the fact that
it's politicized and there's people
being like no it's kind of okay it's
like so shocking to me well it's like
even if it's even if the argument is
that like it if they're saying like oh
it's they're making it out like this
happens in larger numbers than it does
it's like well if it happens at all
right that's the problem isn't that
worth making a movie about like you guys
make movies about things that are
incredibly rare all the time Dave it's
not that if it happens at all it
actually is happening more and more and
more and more so it's not just a tiny
little blip on the radar right there no
I'm just making the point that even if
it was it would still be legitimate to
actually raise awareness act and people
that are basically trying to minimize it
and marginalize it I don't understand
why well clearly I think obviously the
reason why it plays into this kind of
bigger uh political by the way I have
not seen the movie yet so I can't uh
comment on it although I'm I'm
definitely going to but clearly it's
like there's something to this idea of
like the evil of preying on children and
the evil of like sexualizing children
that is something that's on everybody's
mind right now and then here's an
example of like the most egregious form
of that and then you see it's it's very
bizarre to see these kind of like
um Progressive types
try who are kind of already have been
caught kind of normalizing the
sexualization of children
um but look there is I was talking about
this just the other day uh there was
that quote um by um what's the uh what's
the beautiful woman's uh name Levine uh
Levin the military uh yes the the
transgender in the middle of a picture
she was making the argument very very
blatantly beautiful woman with a penis
gorgeous uh she was making the argument
that like kids can uh kids can choose
yeah this former rear Admiral gentlemen
this is your health this is what
Democrats voted for as your health
expert this is a Navy Admiral
health expert well uh overweight man
that looks that this is a overweight man
thinks he's a woman
she was a point so so yeah so this dude
was talking about um Dave how dare you
I'm sorry sorry so so it was a comment
about how um that kids uh you know um
that pubescent children should be
allowed to make the decision to uh get
hormone treatment and puberty blockers
because they know what puberty they're
supposed to go through and they know
this and look it it is obviously just
the idea of giving kids puberty blockers
or hormone is like horrific but there's
something almost more fundamental uh to
the foundational claim there which is
essentially that children can consent
because if you can consent to this
I mean you that that is the most
permanent life that is so much greater
of a decision than having sex or having
a tattoo or getting drunk you're talking
about permanent lifelong decisions
you need to be 21 to drink but you can
be 10 years old and cut your dick this
isn't the worst part about it there's
already a state that passed that if
parents don't affirm this [__] when
their kids are minors they could they
could take your kids from you I don't
know when that was proposed by the way
California they just luckily they just
vetoed it but uh because of one party
them that that has all the power in
California they just vote uh that uh uh
beat a pedophile or or sells uh having
sex with a minor or or sex trafficking
for minors is not of uh considered a bad
crime they literally just voted for that
and they got so much backlash that they
had to switch it over but it just
happened SB something in California they
literally just passed that so I'm saying
like there is something to fight off and
there
I hope people realize you know Tucker
Carlson gave up you know he gave that
speech it was the last speech right
before he got fired from Fox and started
the Twitter show and he had a point in
there that I thought was really really
profound where he was just saying that
like this isn't really a political
battle like this is a theological battle
when you get into terms like like the
idea that like pray you shouldn't prey
on children is not a right-wing view
it's not a left-wing view yeah you know
what I mean this is normal no this is
view this is a good versus evil yeah
like and there's really no other way to
spiritual battle that other than that
Ephesians 6 11. that's it that's right
so then if it's not political then why
is it political well the political
process is being used but the point I'm
making when I say it's not political is
that it's not as if like if you get into
a if the the idea is if if you propose
that um taxing wealthy people and
redistributing that money makes for a
more just society and then I want to
argue well no actually in fact lowering
taxes allows those wealthy people to
invest in companies creating more jobs
and expanding the economy we're having a
political debate if you say I think we
should be preying on your children and
propagandizing them I'm not having a
political debate
because they're using the power of
government yes I mean there's just
there's no more like it's just the realm
is now in like a it's a theological
debate you're talking about child
sacrifice now this is not like it's just
it's a different uh type of debate it's
political because obviously laws and
politicians are involved in it I'm just
saying that it's like you almost have to
conceive of it in a different way this
isn't left wing versus right wing like
we have these different political
ideologies that I disagree with each
other it's a moral I disagree
I disagree there's not political one
that is not left versus right 100 it is
and it just is I don't I don't care what
anybody says it's the truth because
there's only one party pushing it that
you communicate your children that
you're gonna get arrested if you don't
affirm their their gender that that all
this the SB [__] there's only one
party pushing it it is 100 political and
it's easily identified on who's pushing
it it's that simple no it is
one political party who's more guilty of
it what I'm arguing is like when you say
the term left wing like historically
what left-wing versus right wing has
meant is that left Wingers uh believed
in egalitarianism and right-wingers
believed in um traditional hierarchies
this doesn't fall into that like this is
a completely different thing that's what
makes it this is a different Beast Dave
that's what makes him more sick yeah no
I know I don't actually think we're
disagreeing that's even no no I know
we're not disagreeing that's what I'm
saying well your tone seems
the fact that it shouldn't be
politicized you're my best friend bro
the fact that that the fact that it's
like it shouldn't be political but it is
for example where's uh Natalia Natalia
uh is sitting right here her her mom
post go watch sounds of freedom and some
goddamn idiot that looks educated you
can look at your mom's Facebook thread I
don't know if you saw it already I'm
going back and forth with this guy he's
like oh it's some Q Anon conspirit
right-wing conspiracy Bro [__] you bro
like what are you talking about I agree
like what are you talking about and I
guarantee you if I look at his voting
card it's gonna have a big ass D on it
is there anything in it about how like
there is something like going on with
the political classes there's no so
there's just this is zero there's no
like consistency
it's a hundred percent there's zero
politics and let me tell you what let me
tell you why I get more upset about it
okay here's all of our cultures have
something going on obviously yours went
through a whole like the Holocaust
everybody's here here's a reality behind
things right now okay right now 30 of
women
foreign
of my people coming up the Border are
being raped and human traffic coming
from the border of Guatemala to Mexico
to the Border
I've sat down in front of graffiti I
recruited this girl she when she was 15
she was gang raped by 12 men and the
only reason that she was saved was
because the lady that was cooking for
the men bought her from there to save
them I've seen this [__] it's not right
winger left wing and there's only one
goddamn party trying to make this okay
and it's not okay it is not no you can't
mutilate your goddamn kids no you should
not lower the law to make it less worse
for these idiots to go to jail it's
defined who's supporting this much my
brother
you're right
I understand you're right to be outraged
it's appalling what's happening to girls
and boys on on uh coming up uh but it
happens to my country brother so I just
I understand my country
the open borders policies or the de
facto open borders policies that you're
talking about of the Biden
Administration they were absolutely
pushed by the entire Republican
administrator the entire Republican
establishment as well Jeb Bush was out
there on the debate stage saying it's an
act of love we have to let them all in
here it wasn't until Donald Trump that
Republicans were even raising this issue
so I'm just saying it's just not there's
a lot of guilty I get it because
obviously the only reason illegal
immigration works is because it's
illegal because you can exploit I get
that both sides profit from that but
there's when we have this remain in
Mexico but again I understand what
you're saying and I totally and I don't
disagree with you everything you're
saying are facts but we're living in
right now and right now when you have
open borders and it incentivizes people
to traffic other people if minor
majority of the people that are being
affected by are my people right now not
400 years ago not your goddamn ancestors
right now yeah I agree in many ways
right now under this Administration for
for people that voting on this President
and it's happening on a local level on a
state level on a community level right
now yeah and that's my issue in many
ways we have the worst of all worlds
because it's it's like these de facto
open borders where to your point it is
still technically illegal so you're
still technically in this black market
where you're not protected by anything
so it's not just open borders because
they're exploited borders would be legal
for everyone to come in and that would
carry with it alive so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]